part of the reason i think massively
multiplayer games are so popular in asia
is partly because the bandwidth and
infrastructure is there they have
they've had bandwidth an infrastructure
that has been miles ahead of where we've
been so they've had more time to kind of
work on it they have there's greater
opportunity for an audience and then on
top of that you have situations with
copyright over there that are
problematic the retail game model the
traditional retail game model is selling
discs and stores has very much been
destroyed by piracy but a massively
multiplayer game is not destroyed by
piracy in fact it is enhanced by piracy
because the Pirates become a network to
distribute the software and the players
they you know they have to connect
online and there's no stealing the game
because you pay as you play and so I
think that that combination plus also
then you also consider the lower
penetration of down of consoles in Asia
is something that kind of has push
people more to the PC and that's the
multiplayer games work well on the pc
and then further you can kind of take it
to kind of a total is kind of a social
angle some people would suggest that is
it that that people in Asia are more
likely to work together on teams they're
more comfortable working that way and
that's what you're going to succeed in
these games it's about forming large
teams and working together and
succeeding so it's a combination of
things but one thing we're definitely
seeing is almost everything that goes
big and succeeds in Asia starts to come
over here we started to see it happening
we saw it initially with
subscription-based games then we saw
microtransactions taking off there and
now they're taking off in in America and
in Europe as well
I think for massively multiplayer games
it's a combination of things one of the
reasons people like to go to games at
all is games give you concrete
achievement in life we seldom get very
clear concrete achievements anything you
achieve it's always like well it could
have been a little better but when
you've made level nine is level nine I
mean there's no you have made it or you
sorta made it or someone made level nine
better than you you made it being gold
star there it is and people like that
concreteness so you take that factor of
the concreteness and then you combine it
with a persistence a lot you know video
games you play them you win them it's
kind of over you turn it off and it's
gone these these massively multiplayer
games are persistent you know you you
become level 9 you turn it off for three
months you come back you're still level
nine you can go to level 10 these can
become something that you do for 10
years 20 years 50 years if you want to
and so people people like that it makes
it more solid it makes it more real
makes it more meaningful then you
combine that with the social interaction
where you have lightweight connection to
people in other words like you're you
don't have to go through all the
headache of forming social commitments
but you still get to do something
meaningful where you work together as a
team and did something that you all can
be proud of so there's a lot of factors
in there that that you know there's
there's really a lot to like